[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 13 juillet bienvenue dans
le journal de la rédaction de tv 60,18
voici les titres la fête nationale c'est
demain dans un instant le programme des
feux d'artifice avoir autour de chez
vous et puis la suite de notre dossier
consacré à l'évènement rencontre ce soir
avec le capitaine leblay à la tête du
centre d'instruction de la garde
républicaine de saint germain en laye
sera porte étendard lors du défilé sur
les champs elysées à paris il n'est pas
que le cheval de zorro tornado c'est
aussi le nom d'un projet autour du
véhicule autonome il s'est déroulé
pendant quatre ans dans l'agglomération
de rambouillet territoire la semaine
dernière les expérimentations ont pris
fin avec un ultime test la circulation
sur route ouverte
enfin l'été a débuté avec ses
incertitudes ou partir avec la
propagation du variant delta du colis de
et si vous la juillet locale pour cette
fois la fin de ce journal nous serons
dans un camping installé dans la cité
royale de versailles
focus également sur le programme des
activités au sein des îles de loisirs
yvelinoise et une funambule dans le ciel
saint quentinois c'est le reportage que
nous n'avons pas pu vous proposer hier
il sera retrouvé à la fin de cette
édition
[Musique]
mais d'abord une nouvelle allocution
pour emmanuel macron hier soir le
président de la république a pris la
parole depuis un lieu inhabituel le
nouveau grand palais pour annoncer de
nouvelles mesures face à la propagation
du variant delta ducobu 19 obligation
d'être vacciné pour les soignants
extension du pass sanitaire nous parlons
de ces annonces avec marie lebey qui est
avec nous par téléphone bonsoir mes
députés la république en marge de la
4ème circonscription des yvelines alors
emmanuel macron est venu en quelque
sorte brise et l'insouciance des
vacances qui régnait ces derniers jours
et notamment avec l'euro qui a pris fin
également il y à peu c'était une prise
de parole nécessaire face à la
propagation de ce variant delta quelques
chiffres 1 plus de 4000 cas en 24 heures
en france et le taux d'incidence qui a
grimpé dans les yvelines de 18 points en
une semaine c'était important cette
prise de parole oui je crois que c'était
une prise de parole importante puisque
ça a permis au chef de l'état de
rappeler que même si on avait eu ces
derniers temps des mesures d'allègement
qui était notamment due à la à la
première vague de vaccination
la crise sanitaire n'était pas lui on
constate depuis quelques jours une
remontée des décontaminations et donc
c'est important aussi que je pense le
président continue de s'engager dans
cette bataille à la fois pour rappeler
qu'il faut collectivement être
respectueux des gestes barrières et
également pour une mesure fort qui a été
annoncé par le président de la
république c'est à l'obligation
vaccinale pour les soignants et non
soignants des hôpitaux cliniques maisons
de retraite établissements pour
personnes en situation de handicap tout
comme pour les professionnels et les
bénévoles 1 qui saute donc au contact
par nom des personnes fragiles à
domicile pourquoi il fallait aller vers
cette vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants et non soignants qui travaille
auprès de ces publics 3 il déjà en
premier jeu c'est un public est
particulièrement exposée aux risques du
coc vite qu'on a réussi à vacciner
massivement donc les mieux protégés mais
comme on l'a dit si le vaccin protège
des formes les plus graves
il n'exclut pas que vous puissiez être
vous même contaminé donc aussi contaminé
vos proches et puis ensuite parce qu'on
constate malheureusement que encore trop
de soignants ne sont pas vaccinés et si
on veut une action efficace pour
endiguer le virus alors que les
personnels soignants sont une catégorie
de population qui est extrêmement
exposées à ce virus il faut absolument
les inciter à aller davantage vers la
vaccination mais je voudrais qu'on
prenne un cas qui est concret l'italie a
c'est la même chose et on constate que
aujourd'hui 97% des soignants sont
vaccinés en italie et qu'il n'y a pas eu
besoin de recourir à des sanctions
ça peut être aussi peut-être un petit
peu la forme de pression psychologique
qui permet à ceux qui attendaient un
petit peu qu'ils n'étaient pas pressés
d'aller vers cette vaccination d'y aller
franchement pour justement casser avec
une obligation 1 qui prendra effet à
partir du 15 septembre alors pour le
reste des français le pass sanitaire est
élargie avec plusieurs dates le 21
juillet passe sanitaires dans les lieux
de loisirs et de culture de plus de 50
personnes par tiers à partir de début
août c'est dans les cafés les
restaurants les centres commerciaux les
hôpitaux et notamment les maisons de
retraite mais aussi pour les voyages en
avion en train en quarts longue distance
alors pas d'obligation vaccinale encore
mais on entend tout de même vers samarie
le bec puisqu'à partir de l'automne les
tests ne seront plus remboursés
je crois que ce qu'on veut depuis le
début tu as écrite une carte est de
convaincre les français du bien fondé de
cette vaccination à la fois que le
vaccin est sûr et efficace pour ceux qui
pourraient avoir des doutes et des
inquiétudes qui sont parfaitement
légitimes et ceci le sens de continuer
de s'appuyer sur les professionnels de
santé pour relayer ce message mais aussi
parce que nous ne souhaitons absolument
pas aller vers des mesures de
confinement
je crois qu'il ya un impact
psychologique à ces mesures un coût
économique aussi qui est important et
parce que nous devons prendre en compte
aujourd'hui que une part de la
population française qui est vacciné ne
souhaite pas devoir
subir des conséquences de ceux qui ne
sont pas vaccinés donc on met en place
des dispositions qui aujourd'hui soit
vous incite à aller vous faire vacciner
si vous estimez que ce n'était pas une
urgence absolue soit si dans certains
cas vous ne souhaitez pas vous faire
vacciner ou vous ne pouvez pas parce
qu'il ya quelques public par exemple et
les femmes enceintes qui ne peuvent pas
se faire vacciner d'aller vers un test
un test sérologique qui vous permet en
fait de savoir si oui ou non vous êtes
positif les dates clés d audio où il ya
les plus de brassage de population pour
nos restaurateurs pour nos commerçants
c'est important qu'on arrive à rester
ouvert et donc il faut pour autant qu'en
tandis que sa quatrième bague on a les
outils pour le faire et je crois qu'il
faut pousser le maximum une dernière
question d'henri le bec aujourd'hui le
hashtag la dictature était parmi les
tendances tweet que répondez vous à ceux
qui disent que ces nouvelles mesures
bafoue en quelque sorte les libertés
individuelles
moi je suis absolument scandalisé par
parfaite comparaison elle elle mais elle
me choque parce que je pense que c'est
nier l'action du gouvernement les
actions qui ont été engagées depuis près
d'un an et demi maintenant protégé les
français
pour les accompagner pour protéger des
entreprises et donc je crois que il faut
savoir raison garder dans le choix des
mots nous allons n'avons faisons tout
pour ne pas aller vers une obligation
vaccinale
nous prenons un certain nombre de
mesures pour freiner cette épidémie nous
voulons aussi permettre à tous ceux qui
sont vaccinées de retrouver leur part de
liberté et je crois que ceux qui
emploient ces mots ne se rendent pas
compte peut-être de ce qui est fait
depuis le début provôté lutter
activement contre contre ce virus
merci marie le bec d'abord it avec nous
député lrm de la 4e circonscription des
yvelines
or depuis les annonces du président le
site d'octo libre pour prendre des
rendez-vous de vaccination a été pris
d'assaut dans les yvelines au 11 juillet
680 4500 63 personnes avaient été
primo-injection plus 17500 en une
semaine le nombre de vaccinations total
progressent également
523 millions 0,87 53000 de plus en une
semaine cet été dans le département
quatre centres seront ouverts à mantes
la jolie saint germain en laye vélizy 2
ou encore au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines que vous avez
vus à l'image ce dernier site a franchi
hier lundi la barre des 250 milles
injection nj - avant la fête nationale
du 14 juillet avec une tradition les
feux d'artifice qui font leur retour
après des annulations en 2020 malgré les
fortes pluies du jour des événements
seront bien maintenu ce soir voici un
programme non exhaustif et notamment
pour les communes d'el en cours et de la
verrière qui ont fait le choix de
mutualiser leurs feux d'artifice avec la
commune également de maurepas
rendez-vous à 23h à la coulée verte et
les défilés animations habituelles ne
seront pas organisées à noter qu'à
voisins le bretonneux le bal populaire
est annulé en raison de la météo trappe
maintient les activités rendez-vous ou
maintenus aussi à guyancourt au jardin
des golgoths à saint germain en laye le
défilé militaire aura bien lieu à 20h
avec un balai et des rendez vous 1 qui
peuvent aussi évoluer avec la météo avec
un contexte toujours incertain n'hésitez
pas à suivre les différents sites
internet de vos communes toute cette
semaine d'ailleurs tv 60,18 met en
lumière cette fête nationale au travers
du dossier de la rédaction
incontournable pendant le défilé
la garde républicaine descend les champs
elysées tous les 14 juillet juste
derrière la fanfare et le colonel on
retrouve le porte étendard et cette
année c'est le capitaine jean-françois
leblay qui aura à cet honneur il dirige
le centre d'instruction de la garde
républicaine à saint germain en laye une
rencontre signé et juliette prigent des
gestes bien précis présentait sabre un
protocole à respecter portait sabres
attention pour marcher en avant ont pas
marre
le capitaine jean-françois le bleis
entraîne pour le jour j
il sera le porte étendard de la garde
républicaine pendant le défilé du 14
juillet dans la carrière c'est lui qui
donne le pas il est en duo avec chopin
son cheval gris qu'il entraîne pour son
premier défilé
alors là on rentre dans une préparation
en vue du 14 juillet donc on habitue les
chevaux gris de l'étendard à travailler
parmi un groupe de chevaux parce que là
il ya beaucoup de chevaux dans la
carrière est en même temps je regarde un
petit peu s'ils sont en condition
physique
suffisante pour pouvoir faire le défilé
dans de bonnes conditions parce que se
défiler d'heure dur quand même
6 heures entouré de la garde à
l'étendard il donne les instructions
pour apprendre à manier le sabre
il faut dire qu'à 55 ans celui qui
dirige le centre d'instruction de saint
germain en laye depuis 2010 9 n'en est
pas à son premier défilé la gendarmerie
c'est une affaire de famille son père
l'était et lui a montré la voie en 36
ans d'ancienneté jean-françois leblay
compte plus rapidement les fois où il
n'a pas participé au défilé du 14
juillet et pourtant chaque année c'est
la même émotion que la première fois la
première fois vous savez plus où donner
de la tête en fait c'est à dire que vous
voyez énormément de monde sur le bord de
la route qui vous acclament jusqu'au
moment où vous monter jusqu'au rond
point de l'étoile avant de descendre les
champs-elysées et c'est très intense
il ya de la couleur il ya d'écrit du
bruit c'est incroyable et vous avez vous
êtes presque spectateurs de vous même
parce que c'est quelque chose d'unique
être porte étendard c'est toujours une
fierté pour lui l'occasion de réaffirmer
chaque année son sentiment
d'appartenance à la nation et à travers
la tenue toute la symbolique de ce rôle
là j'ai par exemple le fanion du son de
l'instruction donc toujours beaucoup de
symbolique les armes de la garde
républicaine
donc lorsque je serai à cheval jeux
positionnerait ce cil dans la botte de
lens
ça me permettra de pouvoir tenir
facilement le l'étendard la grenade de
gendarmerie qu'on retrouve à différents
endroits sur l'harnachement l'uniforme
légale en jaune sur le tapis pour les
officiers les chaperons qui viennent
habiller la selle ou encore le sabre
modèle 1822 pour se défendre tout un
attirail que le capitaine leblay devra
mettre pour le défilé du 14 juillet
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité les pilotes
pour tornado dans le sud yvelines ce
projet autour du véhicule autonome s'est
déroulé pendant quatre ans dans
l'agglomération de rambouillet
territoire l objectif favoriser la
mobilité en zones peu denses pendant une
semaine d'ultimes tests ont été réalisés
dans le parc d'activités du bel air à
rambouillet et pour la première fois sur
route ouverte
reportage difficile de passer inaperçu
pour ces deux véhicules autonomes
il embarque notamment des systèmes de
localisation de perception et de
communication avec l'extérieur c'est
renault zoé électriques ont roulé du 5
au 9 juillet dans le parc d'activités du
bel air à rambouillet une première
circulation sur route ouverte avec la
traversée de ronds-points et deux
configurations l'une classique sans
aménagement particulier l'autre avec le
giratoire de la rd 150 équipés de
caméras ces caméras filment le carrefour
détecte les usagers de la route et
transmettre leurs positions au véhicule
autonome par des modems sans fil de
communication sans fil pour prendre ses
décisions la voiture embarque un système
de navigation fonctionnant grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle l'objectif
pour les membres du laboratoire
heudiasyc qui ont mené ces
expérimentations démontrer l'interaction
entre le véhicule autonome et
l'infrastructure intelligente et
garantir un niveau de sécurité maximum
faire qu'un véhicule autonome s'insère
dans ce genre de carrefour est
particulièrement complexe c'est vraiment
important que l'infrastructure avec ses
caméras aide le véhicule autonome a bien
percevoir à mieux anticiper ce qui se
passe et de façon à ce que sa navigation
soit soit très sûr parce que ce qu'on
veut éviter absolument quand on a un
véhicule autonome c'est qu'ils créent
des côtes des accidents qui rentrent en
collision
une semaine de test qui vient clôturer
un projet de quatre ans son nom tornado
à son initiative rambouillet territoire
qui a accueilli l'expérimentation
faciliter son déroulement 70 habitants
ils ont également collaboré pour
l'agglomération le défi est immense
répondre à la problématique de la
mobilité en zone rurale pour moi c'est
un vrai sujet de rayonnement du
territoire de montrer que notre
agglomération est un agglomération
innovante qui est capable de briller
du service de très haute technologie de
très haute valeur ajoutée et bah c'est
une impulsion qui est donnée pour qu on
poursuivra tant d'ado 3 je l'espère de
l'appel de mes voeux dès que possible en
y candidate rats ces tests ont démontré
que le véhicule autonome réagissait plus
tardivement dans des carrefours non
équipé d'infrastructures intelligentes
les ultimes conclusions seront révélées
après analyse des enregistrements
effectués lors de l'expérimentation
séance du conseil d'administration de le
pays
yveline hauts-de-seine les élus de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental se réunissait à la
scène musicale à boulogne billancourt
deux semaines après le scrutin des
départementales au programme l'élection
du président avec une nouveauté
pierre bédier prend la tête de
l'établissement le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines succède à son
homologue des hauts-de-seine georges
siffredi qui devient lui vice président
le mandat pas sous présidence yvelinoise
pour respecter le choix fait en 2016 et
respecter la décision de l'ancien
président patrick devedjian décédé l'an
passé pour rappel les deux départements
ont entamé une stratégie de
rapprochement depuis 2016 mais la fusion
n'est plus à l'ordre du jour pour le
moment écoutez cette interview de pierre
bédier recueillis par mélanie poker la
fusion n'est plus à l'ordre du jour à
partir du moment où on ne nous fait plus
une métropole qui d'un côté et scruter
les yvelines et qui de l'autre absorbe
les hauts-de-seine dans un magma de
mauvaise gestion paris seine-saint-denis
même si je pense que la gauche va être
moins alerte puisque le département du
val de marne qui pouvait assurer à la
majorité est passée dans une majorité de
droite et de centre donc mais le
principe même de cette fusion n'est pas
abandonné à partir du moment la
métropole parisienne ne sera pas défini
selon nos voeux qui sont non pas les
voeux de ce que veulent les élus mais de
ce qui est bon pour la population nous
sommes là pour défendre les intérêts de
la population
et bien ce projet de fusion restent
l'armé au pied on n'est pas pro actif
mais nous ne serons pas inactifs après
trois ans de rénovation l'auberge des
trois hameaux à choisel vient d'être
inaugurée c'était en présence de
nombreux élus dont gérard larcher le
président du sénat
cette réhabilitation a pu voir le jour
grâce à différents fonds
dc pos départementaux et régionaux célia
de son go et au nord si nos caisses
c'est la renaissance d'une auberge fermé
en 1965 l'auberge des trois hameaux à
choisel était devenu une maison
d'habitation
puis la commune a décidé de la racheter
en 2017
l'inauguration a eu lieu en présence de
nombreux élus dont gérard larcher
président du sénat qui a apporté son
soutien à ce projet c'est le fruit de la
volonté d'abord d'une équipe municipale
et aussi d'un chef d'entreprise qui a eu
le courage de s'engager et les temps ne
sont pas faciles pour cet engagement
c'est aussi le fruit du soutien du
département de la région ils ont aidé à
concevoir à financer accompagner ce
projet d'auberge c'est une choisel yen
qui a été choisie pour être la gérante
de l'établissement
après plusieurs candidatures avec une
salle de 80 m² 50 couverts l'auberge des
trois mots propose une cuisine
traditionnelle française
plus qu'un simple restaurant cet
établissement est un lieu de passage
on a mis en place un relais colis ou on
va accueillir les jeunes choisis lien le
mercredi midi à l'auberge à manger
on est sur la kz2 l'avait losséni donc
on va accueillir des cyclistes on va
accueillir des randonneurs voilà c'est
un endroit un peu à la croisée de
plusieurs chemins seul commerce et de
choisel un million d'euros a été investi
pour concrétiser ce projet de rénovation
c'est quand même un travail de plus de
trois années déjà d'avoir un lieu de
convivialité d'accueil sur choisel mais
aussi d'activités économiques qui est
créatrice d'emplois
ce lieu accueillera aussi un gîte à
laitages pour six personnes
malgré des conditions climatiques pas
toujours évident des touristes français
ou étrangers ont choisi les yvelines
pour passer quelques jours ou quelques
semaines de vacances et pourquoi pas
vous michael et demi d'euros et nicolas
landry se sont rendus dans un camping à
versailles regarder
[Musique]
les grandes vacances d'été ont débuté la
semaine dernière en france et dans les
yvelines nous sommes au camping de
versailles à mes côtés une famille qui
vient d'auvergne pour passer à ses
vacances alors madame quand ça se passe
ses vacances ici il va très bien profite
de la région fait des visites france
miniature le château touahri donc belle
région malgré le temps oui justement la
météo n'est pas au beau fixe comment
vous faites mais on est sous tente donc
on fait avec et puis on profite de
l'infrastructure de du camping de la
piscine est tout ce qu intérieure
[Musique]
comment ça se passe vraiment dans ce
camping vous fait des activités hockey
ce que vous faites
disons que le matin nous prenant le
petit déjeuner nous partons pour une
visite
aux alentours et puis aux alentours en
début d'après-midi nous sommes de retour
et nous faisons soit une petite sieste
nous allons à la piscine
nous jouons cartes nous venir prendre un
verre et ensuite c'est l'heure de la
douche et du repas du soir des choses
assez tranquille on va dire justement on
va continuer ou vous allez continuer
votre partie de cartes
il y a environ entre 70 et 75 % de taux
d'occupation ici dans ce camping de
versailles
margot vous êtes la responsable est ce
que vous confirmez 70 à 75 %
d'occupation
oui tout à fait là surtout depuis le
début des vacances depuis le début du
mois de juillet on voit aussi que
certaines frontières se sont réouvertes
donc on à la clientèle internationale
qui est au rendez vous ici au camping
des clients internationaux des français
peut être également tout à fait rond n'a
plus sur les hébergements insolites
une cliente elle-même francilienne
plutôt originaires d'île de france
mais après sur les emplacements plutôt
néerlandaise et allemande
la météo ça joue forcément sur le taux
d'occupation d'un lieu comme celui-là
tout à fait surtout hors vacances
scolaires où on va avoir des week-end
bien rempli avec le beau temps mais
après voilà on a aussi des activités à
faire par mauvais temps et la clientèle
est aussi au rendez-vous et bien occupé
on vous souhaite en tout cas un meilleur
temps la météo devrait à revenir au beau
fixe à partir de la fin de la semaine
une saison estivale qui est déjà lancé
depuis une semaine et les îles de
loisirs se prépare à l'afflux des
visiteurs alors on en parle souvent de
la météo mais elle espère t il de
loisirs une meilleure météo justement
pour lancer définitivement cette saison
célia tsongo les kayaks sont déjà de
sortie mais peu de kayakistes en vue sur
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
nathan le soleil mais les activités ne
manqueront pas cet été au programme mini
golf balades énigmes quad karting ou
encore parcours acrobatiques pour cette
saison cette activité purement estivale
a été agrandi un parcours supplémentaire
et puis le doublement du parcours le
plus difficile en fait le parcours noir
donc voilà l'objectif étant d'apporter
plus de fluidité à la pratique ça c'est
vraiment la grosse nouveauté pour autant
les contraintes sanitaires ne sont
jamais loin
la distanciation cela dans toutes les
activités c'est quelque chose qui est
prise en compte et le port du masque un
certain moment même sur des activités en
extérieur exemple parcours acrobatique
en hauteur quand il faut s'équiper
lassé masque obligatoire à partir de 5
ans des temps forts viendront ponctuer
l'été comme le village sportif et
culturel à destination des jeunes et des
familles le judo tour donnera des
initiations gratuites et un cinéma de
plein air sera mise en place en fonction
des événements les jauges seront seront
différentes sur le village sportif et
culturel
on a à z des ateliers avec 12 personnes
maximum sur 4 ha donc on aura 150
personnes au maximum sur l'eau sur
l'espace même protocole du côté des
étangs de hollande
depuis le 1er juillet la jauge est passé
à 1000 personnes sur place mais les
contraintes sanitaires tendent à
s'assouplir
a priori moins de gestes barrières
effectivement je vérifie parce qu'à
chaque fois vous savez c est un peu mou
vent ça peut changer à la dernière
minute donc oui effectivement un
allègement général des mesures tout en
étant restant précautionneux les
visiteurs pourront donc apprécier la
baignade et le bronzage mais aussi des
activités comme le pédalo le mini golf
ou encore le kayak la base de loisirs
est un élément majeur d'attractivité du
territoire sur l'aspect bien sûr sports
loisirs mais aussi tourisme c'est un
site absolument remarquable qui est un
atout pour pour le sud yvelines sur une
saison de mai à septembre sans qu'ovide
50000 visiteurs étaient présents sur le
site
les responsables espèrent se rapprocher
de ce nombre cette année si les
conditions sanitaires le permettent
et puis retour sur cette performance
pour refermer ce journal samedi à
guyancourt tatiana mossot bonganga s'est
élancée sur un fil de 20 mètres 1 me à
fin fils de 20 mètres de haut pour une
performance de funambule spectacles
proposés hors les murs par le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'artiste à
relier le toit de la bibliothèque
universitaire à l'immeuble edison à
guyancourt
mélanie poké patrick jacques de dixmude
et bixente mais rien senti steban
[Musique]
une performance de haut vol le jeu de
mot est facile pour un exploit qui ne
l'est pas la pluie et le vent n'ont pas
fait trembler tatiana mossot bokonga la
funambule à surplomber la perspective de
marta pan accompagnés d'artistes en live
[Musique]
mais on
ce qu'on défend avec la compagnie c'est
qu'il n'ya pas juste une funambule il ya
des musiciens et il ya aussi tout un tas
de personnes qui viennent nous aider
parce que vous avez vu les cavaliers
teese qui sont tenus par part par des
personnes c'est des habitants de saint
quentin en yvelines
donc ouais c'est aussi la rencontre et
le fait de vivre quelque chose tous
ensemble un quart d'heure de traversée
d'une longueur de 100 m à 20 mètres de
hauteur
l'artiste a enchaîné les figures malgré
le temps le public était venu en nombre
la grâce de sept funambules la beauté
des figures la musique toutes
magnifiques un beau grand spectacle au
coeur de saint quentin c'est chouette
c'est super g première fois que je vois
ça c'est vraiment très audacieux
incroyable mais je voudrais vraiment pas
le faire j'ai trouvé que c'était
chouette que elle était très forte pour
pour faire ça c'était impressionnant
c'était même stressant pour nous
peut-être plus que pour elle c'est
incroyable
[Musique]
une performance vécu entre inquiétude
l'artiste évolue son sécurité et poésie
par le public un moment sur le fil
[Musique]
racontez nous
une performance réalisée par une
professionnelle ne reflète bien sûr pas
ça chez vous voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité retour
de l'information en direct l'information
locale et jeudi dès 18 heures belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]